welcome to your weekend ticket first
will recap last week in box office
numbers then we'll let you know what's
new in theaters this weekend and finally
we'll leave you with some new releases
to stream at home on Fandango now this
weekend's box office ended up being a
photo finish footrace between a CGI
Hedgehog and a CGI dog but in that
scenario you've got a bet on Sonic Sonic
the Hedgehog won the box office for a
second weekend in a row with another 26
million earned domestic the video game
adaptation has already zoomed to more
than 200 million worldwide after only 10
days in theaters coming in a close
second was the newest version of the
call of the wild this adaptation of Jack
London's classic adventure story earned
not just 25 million for the weekend but
also star Harrison Ford's highest
non-sequel opening sense Ender's Game
opened at 27 million back in 2013 and on
fewer screens but expanding soon to a
theater near you the newest adaptation
of Jane Austen's Emma posted the highest
per screen average of 2020 so far with
46 K per screen per day this Emma stars
Anna Taylor joy is the titular
matchmaker and it adds more screens this
weekend before expanding nationwide on
March 6th new in theaters this weekend
is the suspense film The Invisible Man
in it a woman's life has turned upside
down when her abusive ex takes his own
life but strangely leaves her his
fortune things don't add up and she
begins seeing signs that maybe he isn't
dead and that maybe an experiment to
make him invisible succeeded or maybe it
didn't and it's all in her head or maybe
it did Elisabeth Moss stars is Cecilia
and a film is directed and co-written by
Leigh Whannell who's worked on other
suspense properties like insidious
upgrade saw and he's even the guy that
was handcuffed to the pipe in the
original song see that's him so poor
Cecilia is probably gonna have to go
through some pretty intense situations
but if you're in the mood for a comedy
instead
maybe you'll enjoy greed greed tells a
story of a billionaire fashion mogul who
in hopes of redeeming his tarnished
reputation decides to throw an extremely
over-the-top party for himself the cast
includes several comedy legends
including Steve Coogan isla Fisher
Stephen Fry and my personal favorite
David Mitchell the director writer
Michael Winterbottom has done a total of
seven movies with the star of the movie
Steve Coogan so we're bound to get some
good stuff out of both of these guys
there are some great oscar-nominated
movies available to stream this weekend
on Fandango now frozen to is finally
available to stream in this chapter Elsa
here's a mysterious voice calling to her
from beyond and Sochi her sister Anna
and the rest of the gang set off to find
its source and learn a forgotten secret
of arendelle they never knew while
frozen - was in theaters it was
considered to have broken the record for
highest grossing animated movie of all
time
beating out the original frozen film and
of course the song into the unknown was
nominated for an Academy Award and will
likely get stuck in your head till
frozen 3 also the oscar-nominated knives
out is available on Fandango now this
weekend writer director Rian Johnson
delivers his take on a whodunit mystery
with a crazy huge cast of a list actors
in the film a wealthy crime novelist
dies leaving an entire family of
untrustworthy characters to defend their
case to the police and an eccentric
detective amidst the reading of the will
knives out is certified fresh' with a 97
percent on Rotten Tomatoes the cast
includes Jamie Lee Curtis Michael
Shannon Don Johnson Toni Collette Daniel
Craig Luke heath Stanfield on a day on
Irma's Christopher Plummer and Chris
Evans cable-knit sweater
oh this oh it's just it's just a little
cold the film was so beloved it'll be
getting a sequel with Rian Johnson
saying it'll focus on Daniel Craig's
detective character and fans on Twitter
are already helping out with a title at
villain the blank wrote knives out - no
Forks given at Stephen Byrne 86
suggested two knives - furious and our
very own Eric Davis writing knives out
it's good that's your weekend ticket let
us know how you think The Invisible Man
and greed will do in theaters this week
and leave us a comment letting us know
what you'll be watching I'm Cal
nonnamous and I'll be back next Tuesday
with more box office numbers new
releases and new movies available to
stream on Finn dango now
[Music]